if you went back and you said Patrick
this is going to be your life or to your
parents Mom Dad this is going to be my
life would they have believed you and
did you believe in yourself nobody would
have believed it nobody would have
believed I wouldn't have believed it I
was always a dreamer you have to know
like I'm the kid that you would walk
home from school and I would ask you
questions I would say so listen you got
four choices
you can be Michael Jackson You Can Be
Michael Jordan you can be the president
of the United States or the richest man
in the world which one do you want and
we would have a 30-minute debate on
which life is a Better Life to Live
While I wouldn't want to be the
president because too much criticism but
I can make some decisions I wouldn't
want to be the billionaire because you
know maybe nobody knows who you are but
you can I would want to be the
billionaire because you can buy this
sports team I'd love to be Michael
Jordan because you can have it all we
would always dream about how one day you
know life could turn into the dreams
that you dream about as a kid